hey guys I'm Dave who's Lucy you've just
been playing dying light the following
so the first big story based expansion
dying light and I played it well I put a
little a little slither of it I played
the beginning and so diagnose all my
favorite games of this year so far I
play it all the times I'm very excited
about the following what do you want to
know like everything so it's any vision
vine light you're in a city park or
hardcore parkour that sort of thing yeah
but the following your go into the farm
so it's it's it's very different because
as you said in dying light you're
playing in the city of Quran and it's
it's big built-up city atmosphere in the
following you're kind of in this farm
big open areas instead of parkouring of
a building to park luring up I like
cliff tops and gaps you know separated
by a fallen tree things like that so
beautiful so what you're doing there
you're playing is Kyle crane again the
Greek name a lot of hard constants in
there a strong name cow crane and there
is a cult and they have been
mysteriously unaffected by the by the
viral and by the virus that has affected
and destroyed so many lives in dying
light the no zombie come pretty much
something so obviously you have to go in
and you have to be like Oh what how are
they unaffected what is going on it
looks when is because the cult leaves
all these beautiful shrines around with
this mysterious figure this mother that
was blessed by the gods they have this
beautiful paintings of everyone there's
a lot of colors more colorful already
than the main game was so that's why
you're there so as you go through you
are kind of finding hints about this
culture and find them but they've also
added in a few gameplay things that
people like the fans have been asking
for and the big one is the crossbow
crossbow is the crossbow you finally
find the crossbow on a farm so there's
like this dead runnerguy then you're
like hey he's holding on to some pretty
cool though this I'm not even gonna lie
to you this basically turns into taro
from
Walking Dead all right with that yeah so
I never really use guns in the main game
and that's a really really hot - I was
carry on with me but I never used it I
can see myself using the crossbow a bit
more because it's quiet and it is it's
really cool as REO P it's pretty much a
one-hit kill so when you use it for the
first time you're kind of standing on a
rooftop and you just pick off all the
zombies beneath you like one by one it's
really great and I think it's gonna be a
really great addition to the main game
and you got to see in action in the next
part of the demo which was when you're
infiltrating kind of obviously there's
all these militia guards and you can
either go in all guns blazing or you can
go in with the crossbow and just pick
them off one by one so it's a great
addition in terms of it just it just
fits right into the gameplay really well
and that allows you to be a bit more
stealthy and stuff think about yeah
because I guess if it's if it's more
open an open environment lends itself to
being a little stealthy flanking tactics
yeah you know the middle little sneaky
dudes your crossbow so they kind of go
hand in hand then cause the thing with
the guns are they're really really
powerful but it also alerted every
single thing of the thing again for your
location so then from there you're
looking for a car but someone's jacked
your rides so but you do find a buggy
it's really fun so I mean the big thing
dinette is obviously you can customize
and you can find good friends for make
stuff basically play the way you want to
and I think it's the same with the
crossbow they'll probably be like
exploding bolts and stuff and with the
card - and you know add mods and easily
what am I gonna pimp your own right
windshield a puppy because if you're
slamming G zombies there's no glass that
it's gonna good but honestly like I
don't know what I expected from it but
it is it's really satisfying to just mow
down loads and loads of zombie support
just just more than um because you you
feel the impact but it doesn't like
throw you off too much it's good I've
always annoyed me about zombie games
which this match means near the car and
if suddenly feels like you're driving
for you to examine yeah exactly
although I don't know if there's gonna
be like in the game there's a humanely
weapon too much it obviously breaks in I
don't know if that's gonna happen we
become a that we quite cool because it's
kind of a risk what they were wearing
with music how much how many zombies
even peel of it and then in the end of
the demo so you're driving huge
beautiful open field and you go over
this big run and there's loads like like
a whole mob of zombies like a forge
beneath you and that is where the demo
ended so I'm really excited to see more
about my fanger awesome so it's coming
as part of the season pass yes so it's
talking to the guys from Tech round and
they were saying that because so many
people actually bought the season pass
it's gonna be included in that or it's
available as a standalone so there is no
release due for the following just yet
official line is it is TBC I'm quite
looking forward to it
I love dynamite promotes army it sounds
pretty interesting so for all your news
on dying light keep it tuned in for
GameSpot
[Music]